[Music]
because Karma's good like if you if you
helped Carol get put on and she gets in
$60,000 raise and Mook gets to move back
to San Francisco her family is that's
just putting good into the world this
portion is like with me so I think this
is one you need to get selfish like
you'd ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is know like
you got to go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's in figure stuff out
this is the television and the
television is the radio so forties
[ __ ] so this is a time where I
think you just kind of go really selfish
and ask your direct question so it's all
started so you know we're the training
manuals base documentation SOP is yep
and biggest problem we have is messaging
and how to make it urgent because small
businesses want to do anything but sit
down and just write out all their their
processes and I feel like a chameleon
with the elevator pitch and trying to
describe what we do so so I'm curious on
how you would hone in on a message
around why a business needs a playbook
or how do you create urgency so might
not be urgency so let's start with that
but one more time because I want to
really understand you're telling an SMB
that they should sit down and create a
manual
we're crowdsource it with other people
so that all their policies processes are
in one place and then training their new
hires the same way and as they grow
everyone's doing things and you want all
that information to sit on your platform
yeah as a SAS business yes understood I
don't I don't think you should make it's
not about urgency I think it's about
money
I think the way you'll get SMB is to
really come in if your message is I the
one of the biggest reasons I'm really
good at SMB marketing is cuz my dad is
like the cliche textbook Central Casting
of like an SMB everything's defense
everything's like short term ROI it's
why they're not getting tricked into
lower funnel it's just lower funnel is
what they do SM B's don't build brand
they're in the sales business everything
is short term it's the nature of the
beast so I love these questions because
it's so easy for me to go into my head
and be like what would get my dad to do
this he would never sit down and do it
on theory he would definitely not do it
because it was good for his employees
it's just not what he is he would
definitely do it if I could convince him
that he's wasting eight thousand three
hundred forty dollars a year because
that's how many hours are being wasted
on managers training people that they
could be doing in selling you need to
turn this into a financial thing you
make one [ __ ] smart video that shows
like humans equal money and they waste
time because they're telling Rick what
did like you just paint them the
scenario like you walk into a liquor
store let's use that one and you go hey
do your managers train your new how your
new people come out well they just [ __ ]
and we throw them into the wild and
you're like do they make mistakes and
wrong stickers are put on things and you
lose money yep and do like your do
sometimes your manager have to bring up
people at the register because they
didn't know what to do at the register
mmm-hmm like do you understand how much
that's actually worth if you take your
average manager to make sixty-five
thousand a year and you take eighty nine
hours a month and then you have to make
this binary Matt ROI thing
how much is your product cost perfect
you need to basically convince all of
them that they're wasting 200 bucks a
month and that you and you're gonna give
them back a hundred bucks it will kill
money in the bank oh I don't know if
I've been more confident of a piece of
advice in four days since we started it
I'm not kidding I'm not kidding I'm that
confident SMBs are by narrowly on
short-term economics if you tell them
you pay me a hundred bucks what they're
very bad at is hitting costs small
businesses are bad at hitting costs
they're there to binary they don't see
the bigger picture and this is obviously
generalizing but it's very cliche
especially when you come from zero cash
is king you're looking at it and you're
not saying like you know
okay straight ROI conversation yep
they just don't want to give me 100
bucks a month for something that's not
gonna be used you got to convince them
that they're wasting 400 bucks a month
on hidden fees on hidden costs that your
thing solves for like literally every
one of them is training through osmosis
which is taking time out of experienced
workers to just teach the new kid what
to do instead of the new kids spending a
week [ __ ] do you understand yeah
totally
okay the other thing we're dealing with
this I've done a lot of content as just
kind of a personal brand and we're we we
hired a Content Manager we hired a video
producer but we're kind of unsure on
what to create content around is it the
business or is it me and how do we you
don't divide that you need to build the
content around commande problems of SMBs
both work those are both I'm agnostic to
that you if you start an entire series
of did you know for SMBs you need them
to watch it I mean just any kind of
content the reason for all of us to do
content is to have somebody watch it to
then create an opportunity whatever that
may be right I'm secretly trying to
crowdsource buying the New York Jets you
know you may want to get more people on
your SAS product so I think that the
place where people spend a lot of time
on is the equipment the lighting the
debate of personal brand versus logo and
what the only thing that matters is make
[ __ ] that people want to watch that you
want to talk to right that makes a lot
of sense for you it's why it's what you
did it's how it's why it's why may seem
unique when you tell it for them the
audience but I so understand it because
when you scratch your own itch and your
itch is your community
it's just perpetual right it's how you
stumble into your thing you were doing
this and like you know and so your job
is to make the best content in the world
for small businesses right you know like
how to hire your spouse your
remember like like yeah definitely not
about documentation that's the curveball
got it
documentation is selfish making a video
where you interview somebody who teaches
people how to fire or relatives is
thinking about small businesses right
right that's what small businesses
that's one of the biggest issues every
SMB has in the world right now how do I
fire my loser cousin my [ __ ] up aunt
my you know how do you know how do I
limit my grandfather's yelling at me
like it's it's human stuff you become
that that's what I always talk about be
the media company and you know don't
make content that's literal to you what
must allowed us to scale as far as just
direct response ads make sense so we
have gotten really good at identifying
the solution here's the product it's
cool but we haven't put too much and
that's what you want to do because it's
gonna get your CAC and your LTV numbers
in a much better place over time
especially when all but what happens
next - this whole Gary Vee era where a
lot of people have one off of the thesis
is every enough money comes in where the
ads don't work anymore that's what
happens next let me tell you what 2022
is gonna be about everybody that plays
up that's why I'm glad you're here you
know you know cuz you're gonna go you're
gonna take advantage of the pay it's why
I'm glad you're here you're taking
advantage of the pay and you need to
build brand do you guys are in the
opposite spectrum and if you don't have
both you become vulnerable vulnerable
you don't get the max upside you can be
more like you know you know I think a
lot about like how I've been thinking a
lot about how I talk like vulnerable
isn't you go out of business
vulnerable is like you don't keep
growing and we don't keep growing things
could happen maybe you're spending too
much in your lifestyle based on their
your businesses and all of a sudden it
stops growing then you actually become
vulnerable those are things I think
about but yeah you have to build brand
I'm curious in scaling so fast at your
how did you make sure the knowledge
transfer happens osmosis yeah so like
you know like I'd like I am not as
competent stew use your product except
for me cuz I'm an entrepreneur and I'm s
and me that's why I know what you need
to do I'm real tricky for you because I
don't care about money either but most
do so it's okay that I'm all the way
over here I'm not gonna be the guy but
like for the SMB that doesn't want to do
it in the the proper way and wants
osmosis she or he will take you up on I
will save you $4,000 here's how you were
and by the way we wasted enormous time
on senior people training people through
osmosis and and where we started
evolving into more products like you is
I started realizing wait a minute not
everybody learns like me so I got these
and F's and so maybe we do need stuff
like this in place how do you think that
have you seen b2b SAS products leverage
influencers and celebrities and that
sort of thing they will they will
sure of course
GoDaddy ran Super Bowl commercials yeah
right you know of course mail MailChimp
you know like like a lot of La Douce
like less expensive like your products
with our marketing what when we really
started to take off keep Donuts and we
got to a point where we were like
tripled our team yep and felt like we
should be producing higher
I didn't hear ya it didn't it didn't go
so it's cuter off keep it valuable
it's not about raw it's about valuable
Star Wars is valuable I go into a
theater I escape for my real life for
three hours like it's escapism you guys
doing high production is not escapism
keep it valuable
you made a commercial and you know
potentially yeah like people think raw
production I think value not value
making a video that looks great but it's
just there for you to get a sale is less
valuable to the other person on the
other end you guys shooting the [ __ ] and
actually talking about real [ __ ] clearly
was more valuable
another thing we just did it was kind of
a test but it felt like a cheap
attention and it was giving the inner
ads and our air in the airport for in
the concourse yeah we don't have a
campaign strategy yet but if you were
trying to target SMB business travelers
in an airport is there like a call to
action or I would do I would do I would
do in that scenario which I like real
life like media like if it's underpriced
I like the idea of going literal are you
a small business do you have a business
problem text us and put a phone number
you collect the data I like that I would
do that you get first party data you can
call them you can see it through you can
see how it's working maybe you make up
maybe you make a funny little Astrid can
be like we will not save your
information maybe you show picture
yourself like you know so you can play
then bounce around will come around
again peon
any workers and First Responder help me
just cuz I wanna get under stood and and
those people you want to get their
attention to be their lawyer now to be
the first person that everybody thinks
of of the hottest people on the scene to
respond to be referral but then also the
deepest relationship which you can have
which is probably mirroring your
identity markers of like Agee Catholic
Sicilian Irish if I could have complete
penetration of those audiences I think
that that would be disproportionately
valuable as you're going after okay keep
talking because I want to ground this
working backwards you have a law firm
and we want to get people's businesses
and so we first responders are are
incredible lead-gen to that if they in
various situations if they know when
like you entrust from the sense that
you've been doing yep
I totally agree so just as somebody who
I guess thank God hasn't been in this
scenario yet and just having dug in some
accident happens and the relatives that
are left over that aren't at the
hospital may look at a cop or a first
responder and say can you give me a
lawyer right now yeah it's cool I just
am never yeah I totally understand
have you thought okay have you have you
considered in parallel building the most
mackerel brand in the general area as
well with the end consumer how long you
been doing it
so I've taped 6 release 4 and what are
you feeling so far it's so early I'm you
know it's funny I've always thought
loiters when I first started talking
about this and like [ __ ] lawyers
right because in a good way in a good
way because I was thinking you know if
you think like I always say what you
know what I'm really good at is not
knowing anything and asking questions
right curiosity and lack of education
has been an incredible foundation for me
but you think about all that stuff on
remanent television where the lawyers
are there right and I'm like you know
and then when I got older I'm like when
I started like just through like being
in a business cocktail you hear like
some of those companies are sizable
businesses and I'm like make sense right
and so when I started going to this
version no different than now like hey
guys make something that's valuable to
people instead of right I was like man I
even think in my earliest videos when I
was talking about personal brand I was
like be the lawyer that tells people all
the real [ __ ] like like like I just feel
like that's great that makes so much
sense to me so now we understand that
now so now what you're asking me is
targeting capabilities that if you're in
a town that all the cops are
irish-american like how do I win that
cohorts groups doing a party once a year
like year I'm gonna have other people
from different like factions within
do amateur awesome love it where are you
based so okay so now that I've got the
landscape a lot better what's the
question
basically a how do I build out
communities that details are details
that Peter every one idea takes to
execute talents Basco about becoming
alpha me 22 years in the psycho and
demographic communities by providing
each one of them what they're looking
for either in the macro or the micro of
what you do for a living so for you know
the reason SMB works for me so much is
like I'm trying to tell them to put out
content about how to fire a relative has
nothing to do with their product but I
know that's a huge value to actual SMBs
I think the answer is you the way I
think about that is you take the how
many different communities do you think
there are intuitively and I think you
what you do is you whiteboard the 10
that you think are the most meaningful
then rank them and then really go deep
in the first three of like really
spending time whether reading whether
actually spending time but it's the
strategy and insights to make what they
like what makes them tick and then
providing that whether through content
form or event form it's really one big
game of reverse engineering like this
was something I've wanted to do for
years but until I felt like everybody
the bar majority of people would leave
here ry+ on their investment
like the thought of like building up
everything I built up we're like YouTube
brothers don't do it and then leave and
then say Gary visa farce I spent 12,000
bucks and it didn't get me anything
that's just stupid business for me I
needed to get to a place where I thought
this was so overwhelming ROI positive
you know and that's how I think about
everything literally everything
sneakers wine vaynermedia until you're
you know until you get to a place and so
that's just what I want you to kind of
do it's like what does what why the only
thing that I can do then
basically copying your model which I've
done for the lower aspects and I can
have all my friends come in and be the
top lawyer guy and that community right
but as I get more awareness in the
first-responder group I would love to
have a show of the fire fire comes
through the car wreck the ER nurse is
the first person in the hospital having
like a little drama with people
throughout the community that I don't
know if you want to go I mean listen you
were just a creative guy I can already
sense that so you just may want to do
that I actually think it's a little less
ER and law-and-order I think you make it
a little bit more so I'm a big fan and
I'm sure you guys have heard this about
like hosting the party I think one of
the things you can do is just create a
podcast network so like I think you
should go find two charismatic nurses
and start a Houston nursing show you're
the executive producer they're the
talent and that becomes a little viral
hit in that community you see where I'm
going I'll give you a real left-field
one if you want to be super creative
you could also this is crazy but I would
love for you to do this I think this is
super cool you could actually be the
livestreamer of the cops and
firefighters on had six people with
live-streaming and actually aired the
softball league games it's yeah I mean
if you're lucky enough and you live one
of those towns where the cops do play
against the firefighters like or you
could literally create the Thanksgiving
game cops versus firefighters get a feel
to get a high school to support it film
it and air it live on Facebook and own
the you know the first responders cup
you can probably get a sponsor to come
over and subsidize all your [ __ ] fees
you could literally throw the [ __ ]
Thanksgiving game every [ __ ] Friday
each like you see where I'm going
I think it's a lot easier to throw I I
think the best thing you can throw is a
literal podcast it's the most likely
thing you can pull off is a podcast
network the next more likely thing you
can pull off is actually airing the
softball games or the football games the
last thing you're probably likely to
pull off is creating er you're not
producing a show that's hard as [ __ ]
scripted that's separate that's
different that's the that's different
that's different that's different that's
different but less reoccurring than the
things and to be one-off once your
interview Karen whereas whereas if
you're doing a show for four nurses in
Houston and just a culture of that and
it's a call-in show you see where I'm
going you want to create things that are
like scalable Wine Library TV was
amazing I tasted wine which meant I
could live for hundred lifetimes and
never get to every wine right askgaryvee
think about the shows I've made the wine
Wine Library TV scaleable in perpetuity
I can't taste every wine in my life not
in a hundred life's a scary be unlimited
questions from the audience
forever daily vlog I actually live just
filming there was there was never I
never had to create see where I'm going
see got it that's where you're looking
for my man and if you're a consumer
right now right home ownership rate is
at 64% in America
it's both spin since the crash 64% of
Americans own a home
adults correct 240 million people 64% is
a high spent long time and by the way I
I just so you know like just to clear
the air when you made your comment about
like owning a home and investing yeah
like I was all about that because your
entrepreneurial yeah right it is yeah
situation a hundred percent and I got
with your current home saying don't ever
own a home I mean it's like you guys
really know if I was if I did a better
job clarifying it yeah I was glad I did
that
but even funny like what I really really
realize is the thing I'm most upset
about or like want to bring up sets on
the wrong word the thing that I would
wish people do it blows my I did it
everybody does it
the number one conversation is let's
stop overextending ourselves with our
down payment it is unbelievable almost
every single person when they buy a home
think the home is such a great
investment that they basically every
dollar they have in liquid is their down
payment then they get a mortgage now
they have no [ __ ] savings and they're
living for that mortgage that's what I'm
that's what like my big thing now is
like you know how like Oprah's started
the whole movement for like you know
with every woman in America like go get
checked up go to the doctor on your
birthday like I'm so proud of like that
was such a smart thing she like found a
very simple way for a lot of women
during the 80s and 90s and early 2000s
to remember to go to the doctor I want
to like create a rule of like whatever
your net power however lik much liquid
you have half of that is what you're
allowed to put on a down payment on your
home cuz that's what I'm seeing that 64
is gonna be 39% when this [ __ ] thing
collapses because everyone's so
overextended they can't support the
mortgage when they lose their job you
know there's a huge misconception in our
industry that you need 20% out
and that is absolutely incorrect in fact
we think we always promote generally as
a trusted adviser that you should put
down as little as possible
assuming you can afford the paper right
because if you're renting you're paying
100% interest to 11 yes and that's what
made everyone in Europe rich and there's
no middle class so at least now in
America it's still affordable it's the
number one way to generate as well so
you know we you don't have that 20% use
your cash cash can use it for other
things like investing yours mm-hm but if
you're gonna live so when you're paying
rent anyway if you're paying 59 bucks a
month or and you are four thousand talk
to me about that perception because I'm
fascinated most places you don't have to
put 20% down
no if you're a veteran it's zero if you
live in the outskirts you need an
agriculture USD loan zero money down FHA
loans three and a half percent down
which you need to get it from my friend
and now there's even crowdsource skill
funding funds allow this kind of pilot
through Freddie Mac if you do a
conventional loan it's 5% down the
perception that comes from that 20% down
you have an 80% loan to value you don't
owe mortgage insurance in addition I say
everyone China would eat tonight I
totally understand it but you're trying
to avoid the amount by spinning all your
cash then you can't mess yourself and
everything else in life and so it's okay
for your cool your first see your first
home it's okay your first-time
homebuyers 32 ok the average age so to
get into the house is what we want
people to because you start generating
Jerry well for you your family
generations to come so as a consumer
yeah but isn't that an interesting look
just for my own like knowledge I think
it's an interesting debate like
generating wealth on something that you
own 80 to 95 percent now to pay off
you're generating an asset in 20 years
right it's an interesting [ __ ] debate
so so so it's you you actually when you
say about cash is king and not putting
it down you're actually making the
argument I understand I understand of
course I understand that you're already
paying rent I totally understand soon
enough
the asset appreciates over time to you
to you to your point to your point what
I need to add layers to is actually the
livelihood I'm thinking about living in
so like there's a big Delta between you
know
where what you're renting what you're
buying it's all one big game the same
thing which is to your point like how
one uses their cash why I love how you
talked about you know a young arm you're
like these guys are perfect examples
dude good job man you're out of Boston's
wait one more you're at the same place
so this dude floats around he's a little
more anchored but you float around yeah
so now so I float around I float around
the whole level 42 you know after I left
Austin I have my first place I bought in
Austin right I mean I bought my condo I
still own it I rent it out mm someone's
paying for that everyone right on that
asset of course I didn't you know I
learned Chicago then with the Tampa I
was only there for six months each move
of four vital I brought multiple
properties in Florida I didn't sell them
and use a cash from the next thing
because I say total all those properties
are not rented out so someone else is
paying for my course in it in my winter
home if I ever did so of course of
course
now the Newport Beach how about another
out there so when you have that
lifestyle and you can float around
Airbnb income is now a verifiable income
source for you to purchase a home as an
individual truck and so you you touch
them on your videos about about you know
maybe don't want to be anchored down but
now that the whole the industry is
evolving as well those that don't want
to anchor down like I have then you can
just run it out because always renters I
mean they're always a renter I pay
warehouse right into a house I pay them
80 bucks a month they take care of it
they Symantec's
how many to be done you have to it cool
yeah total again like and someone's
paying for my love I love it good okay
so if you're a consumer and you're
trying to find no - you're looking about
nine point three nine twenty different
places for information when you're
trying to come up with buying a home
online okay so those eyeballs are out
there they're on YouTube there are much
everything you have on tops right so
then when you want to actually engage
a quilt ready buyer you know if you ask
the first time homebuyer look what you
think of when you think a mortgage right
they'll be like I don't know
rocket mortgage right so rocket mortgage
is a call center in Detroit I'm aware
that's it so if I'm a Spanish speaker
miami-dade I'm gonna talk to some little
white dude on a headset in Detroit to
get my loan that might but Dan Gilbert's
ability to get somebody who can speak
Spanish is not very hard not to not to
of course they have them so that's got
arguments not gonna play no but the art
though is that that local experts have
local knowledge that only a local expert
right so so we want to bring this back
down to the community level right so you
know you you're in your community we're
all deeply within our community a real
estate agent or a loan originator has
knowledge in their brain about their
local community like that's a good
neighborhood that's bad neighborhood
here's a minister that ok I know where
you work I know where you're going
I got a hedge guy this is the bad school
this is a good school all those things
yep those those knowledge bases right
there they aren't out there in the
FinTech world I understand there are
built up over living in the community
for 10 20 30 40 years what what what the
FinTech companies are gonna do is win
the top of the funnel and then address
those things underneath that's right but
that's right so so there's a
commoditization going on an industry
correct Ilse given by price the correct
and brand this is this is this is my
whole argument like you're not gonna
beat technology the only thing that's
gonna allow anybody to survive as things
get commoditized and driven down the
internet will drive everything to the
lowest dollar and you're not gonna beat
somebody who's much more well-funded
than you the only thing that plays is
brand-n degree which is why we're here
in all these fin tech companies they're
they're not they're not coming here they
are there our business is filled with
old stodgy bankers right like so what I
brand myself and my reputation as you
put it on we did so I put out videos of
myself
I'm the holy sea level executive our
industry the only owner of a
Linder it's literally talking about like
hey I went to this mortgage event last
week and I saw Darren Hardy speak and he
said this this and this you know and and
you know by the way when you're in a
business meeting and it did funny how
you know someone who's like you know
grabbing an eye or scratch the nose and
you know you're about to shake that
person's hand
let's just be self-aware of some like
that so I don't like even with that I
cannot tell you if I go everywhere I go
these just don't love your videos I love
your content it's hilarious of course
you know and so yes so brand that's
refraining to our subscriber Neverland
you're talking about the end user and I
understand yeah I need them to they're
gonna pay for ninety-five a month just
start we already have about two hundred
seventy subscribers I'm gonna load the
game plan is to have seventy five
hundred real estate agents and seventy
five hundred loan originators within
three years I think that's super doable
we need to brand to the consumer that's
that's this part this is what I'm here
for this is I want the consumer to know
so what your consumer and you think
mortgage you think rocket mortgage you
might say Lending Tree because some
branding out there or you just might say
I don't know and so 10 which is which
means which means then you go to Google
and then it becomes a tollbooth game
your industry and much many service
providers for the last 15 years have
been playing one big game of whoever was
the layer above Google itself won the
next tier one OpenTable billion dollar
company Priceline Angie's List home
advisor this is all the same [ __ ] Google
was the toll booth everybody
that was localized or was a big player
before was was emotional on why they're
better than the Internet
some people got funding one Google
search and became the [ __ ] winners
and right now it's clear they bought all
the AdWords I'm aware I'm aware but I
research I love you can't do you can't
do search it's too expensive for you
search if I was Gary Vee into that I
built on search everybody's like he want
on social I want on search an email the
reason I I won bigger on social because
I'm like oh this is the same thing and
this time I got smart I'm like I'm gonna
invest in this [ __ ] right then that's
how I won then the next year was [ __ ]
I'm
do it to myself I'm gonna become the top
of the funnel because then I can [ __ ]
open wine or a sneaker or [ __ ] I can
open a vein or anything and be a player
I can build a real real estate brokerage
right now Vayner Realty help you build
your personal brand that's the only
thing that actually matters and I'm
gonna take a smaller cut then Remax I'm
a problem I'm aware so that's that's why
I'm excited about this conversation so
so the economics are gonna play itself
out this is not brother
you you've got this figured out it's
only that and so I like where this
conversation is going because I think
you've got the groundwork and now let me
give you the answer everything for you
has to be building the brand in places
that are under priced that you could
afford
so step number one give me this verbatim
you have to go hit up every single
mortgage and real estate podcast that
exists email them I don't care [ __ ] if
they have eight [ __ ] listeners email
them and offer them as little money as
possible for them to live read your
commercial at the top of the podcast and
that goes for all of you like small
business shows lawyer shut like I don't
give a [ __ ] if they're in Denver like
shit's funny how it actually trickles
down so you need to win podcast pre-roll
because I think it's grossly underpriced
cuz nobody knows what its costs so
that's huge YouTube videos targeted
against search queries from Google the
place where quicken and opentable and
all those guys haven't gotten to yet at
the scale that makes it impossible for
you is YouTube pre-roll based on search
query on Google if you then can use your
personality or whatever else you come up
with whatever your Geico or MetLife is
right MetLife decide to use Snoopy Geico
decided to every six months do something
funny if you have that as a pre-roll you
know Gary Vaynerchuk goes and looks for
home or whatever terms are important in
your world but then goes watches a Jets
video on YouTube but Google has both
sides of that funnel and your pre
rolling and you're like are you in the
market for a home I'm like I am before I
watch that Jets video that's another
play that will absolutely work for you
but most of all
this is for all of you as well becoming
the media company you become the
Tollbooth
you become Google instead of being the
second-tier that's why I built garyvee
because it's all going to alexa this is
all going to I mean this is how it's
gonna work
hey Alexa I need a mortgage Amazon's the
problem hey Google
I need a chiropractor that's how it's
gonna work and unless you're in the
business of you know if it's like hey
Alexa I need a social media agency
Alexa's the problem hey Alexa what's
vaynermedia's phone number that's the
difference that's all it's gonna be left
that's all that's gonna be left will it
get to your industry will it get there
fast enough that you give a [ __ ]
financially but in the end that's the
world brand nothing else that's what it
is that's what you have to do that's why
content matters that's why building your
personal brand matters building your
company matters content content content
because that's your only leverage
against highly funded multi-trillion
dollar funded global companies that are
gonna try to get everything agreed
so we're branding ourselves we're we're
trying a couple different methods we're
starting with YouTube videos like for
example if you searched you know but the
five things you should know about being
a first-time home buyer or six pitfalls
to avoid
yep when listing a home you know so
we're putting out video content our
first our first wave I guess if you will
of marketing and building these data
funnels is about using Sabrina Bryan as
our spokesperson from Cheetah Girls just
because she's free and she's part of our
and she's a friend of ours so and she's
got a whole some pretty sounds right to
me we also have free and wholesome
sounds great right so you know if
someone if someone picks that video
income
no they're either looking to buy at home
we're looking to list a home and then we
know we can filter them out on our
website so it again the idea is to give
a consumer like if you go to Lending
Tree you go to Zillow go to rocket
mortgage just to talk to someone there
just to talk to someone you have to
enter all this information I understand
so when I do anything that smart written
freely giving away every single accident
that's right that's right through the
eyes advanced writing and then the
consumer chooses okay couldn't agree
more here's my zip code brother whoever
brings the most value to customer wins
and what the last generation was about
was give me your data before anybody
knew how much data was worth and I'll
give you free stuff and we were all
pumped I mean you know you some of you
are too young but like for real like it
was like whoa
2002 2001 2003 for like I'll give my
email a name but I get this for free
instead of buying it others magazine for
9 bucks it's amazing now we understand
the data is invaluable we're more
reserved we're a little more thoughtful
we'll give it I still think we're giving
it the privacy thing is grossly
overrated we don't give a [ __ ] we don't
we're doing it every day the mainstream
media is trying to make us scared every
day we put all our [ __ ] information
every day we want convenience the reason
I like yours is not so much that I'm
giving up the information I just don't
want to give up the two minutes to fill
out all the [ __ ] time of course when you
transact you're giving information but
the fact that you're putting it in the
front that's what I do I give away all
my best stuff for free in perpetuity
with maybe some rationale eventually
something might happen I'm playing the
ultimate game of it right the bad
version of me is I give a little and
it's really a funnel for you to pay me
$4,000 a month to be in my mastermind
right we're all be scalable and sell you
$197 ebook on how to do this those guys
we struggle a little bit with without
whether to brand individually one of our
co-founders or whether we should you
know both they answer to all of us both
okay cool cuz any of this kind of has a
you both both that's okay
it's it's it's it's not only okay it's a
priority and my recommendation some
people like the person and some people
don't
thus you should do both some people love
the idea of like doing business with the
person they see on the other side of
video some people like to think that
it's an organization my no friction for
the end-user that is my religion well I
don't wanna donate time I think it's a
lot of things but I want to say you know
I just I just got this Samsung S 10 plus
with one terabyte internal memory Bailey
and it came with tick-tock and you've
been talked about tick tock and it's
amazing the amount of views and eyeballs
that are on that I mean there just
happen to be eight to twelve years old
right there is but not like like of
course but but but 18 to 24 is on
Instagram like tick tock is 8 to 12 no
listen I mean I think I think that well
don't confuse the content producer with
the content consumer okay got it you're
not seeing it because people produce it
I mean I'm producing tick tock
cuz I want nine-year-olds to be Gary Vee
fans now I'm super in well that's going
[ __ ] 5 yeah because a nine-year-old is
doing business like like I genuinely
think that there's a very substantial
chance that one of my biggest investment
payoffs will be somebody who's nine
years old now and when she or he is
building the next Facebook demands that
I'm an investor and that I will be able
to talk on stage in 21 years that my two
billion dollar exit on the Amazon of its
day was predicated because I was making
tick-tock and little v content
and that became the gateway drug to Sara
wanting to me to be an investor and
that's how I got the deal we want that
long game as well
yeah I mean like I don't understand how
people don't I'm 43 like like in like 12
years I'm gonna be 55 like I'm gonna be
young I'm gonna young people don't think
long term so there's like tic TOCs a
waste of time like cool I'll take all
those customers I'm not selling any
nine-year-old wine now hopefully house
exactly nothing else you'll see a trend
in there that makes you a better creator
on Instagram people don't see hidden
value it's like this hidden cost people
are too literal that's what they said
about social media as a whole the reason
nobody went into social media was it was
for kids that's what Facebook was
Facebook literally was made fun of on a
daily basis in real business because I
was in real business for being four kids
now it's only for 60 to 80 year olds
so you talk about brand I'm confused
about the right hook aspect of it good
so I'm building brand building brand
building brand and I provided solutions
to people solution they can buy what I'm
using but I don't I haven't we talked a
lot about earlier this morning about you
know advertising and taking advantage of
the opportunity what's your what's your
take I mean how do you want it so real
quick real quick one thing is it's
working I think you might be thinking
I'm gonna give you a different
perspective that thing you're gonna
enjoy I think you should amplify your
jabs not your right hooks that's it so
spend money on the jab because the jab I
do people buy the stuff but I don't even
talk about it it's magical you're more
Larry Holmes than your Mike Tyson me too
me too
Larry Holmes held the title longer too
Mike Tyson second question
building building media team yes
not knowing that first part really
resonated with you right yeah you got it
you're done you're set you properly
thought about amplified cuz adverting
goosebumps advertising comes synonymous
with selling so you were like [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna spend money in general I don't
like throwing right hooks cuz I'm so
good at chat right and like [ __ ] what am
I gonna do
that's isn't that fun you sold out yeah
dude I still get mad about that I get it
I guess I'm same way that's why I wrote
the [ __ ] book I literally thought
about it so much from 2007 eight nine
ten eleven I finally got to what's
ironic about Jab Jab Jab right hook was
on paper it seemed like I was trying to
help all the people who are always
selling which I was it's like slow it
down like a little romance you know
ironically it ended up helping more
people that were all jabbing you and I
are probably unique in the fact that our
jabs back to Larry Holmes are so
effective that we win there's a whole
group of people who just give give give
and they actually have to ask and they
were scared to ask a lot of people
aren't natural salespeople a lot of
people are scared to make that move it
was really funny to watch a play out I
think I absolutely thought it was gonna
be all the those guys be like slow it
down a little romance right like get
value it ended up being a bigger
breakthrough for people that were giving
value but not making any money because
they didn't know how to ask it's
interesting anyway you're gonna kill by
amplifying jabs because you're clearly
bringing value brother the only reason
you're selling so much stuff is because
you're bringing so much value I'm so I
want you to make more people see the
thing that you're bringing value in I
spend all my at 80% of my ad money
excuse me unless I'm selling sneakers or
wine just because I'm learning
plus I have a unique life where I have
to use myself to understand certain
things that I have to use for the agency
so I'm even doing things that I don't
necessarily want to be doing like
selling wine and sneakers at some level
because it helps us so much with Boehner
because my clients care about selling
product but I spend almost all my ad
money on the content that organically
shows me it's doing best and brings the
most value and then I spend my own money
to help more people get value because I
know it resonates with people that's
right my big thing where I really made
out and this is where it's a little bit
different potentially for what I know
about you is I don't need to sell a
single thing as garyvee because I
actually run vaynermedia I really
[ __ ] put myself in a good spot where
I have zero need to monetize my audience
so does my retail business yes that's
where I can get real good though I like
what I'm hearing in the relationship you
have with your audience seems like it's
organic seems like you're selling things
you believe it listen nothing is more
exciting than selling something you
believe in this the second you get paid
a million dollars under the table to
even sell the glue that's when you're
[ __ ] but if you're actually selling
something you actually believe in you'll
[ __ ] win my biggest problem with
people is they sell something they don't
believe in they just it's the thing that
they've stumbled into it's the thing
that they just think they'll make the
most money on that's the thing that
makes the most vulnerable super long
term if you [ __ ] love it and you
believe in it there's a lot of things I
could be selling that would make me a
lot more money you know I'm helping
people when I do track like I do things
I want to be doing like I love showing
people how to make that have 20 bucks
how to like start living their life with
more money that's why I do trash talk
there's literally people that leave
comments like gara view this is not
going to help you buy the Jets no [ __ ]
dick I understand that eight hours of my
time is not making three hundred nine
dollars is not necessarily the
mathematical equation to get to the Jets
but is it because if I helped 40 million
people live a much better life if I'm
two hundred million dollars short when
the time comes can i crowd fund the last
part I think so buy your wife
just on your free advice I'm completely
convinced but when a time comes this
whole country is gonna demand that I own
the Jets not want it I really believe
that I really genuinely believe that
full penetration completely massive
awareness i I still would much prefer to
be capable of doing it myself because I
don't like to ask which is really a
funny thing if like then I ask the whole
world you know it's like almost like
back to Who I am pulling from opposite
directions so that's what I think yes
doing it yourself or hiring yes oh I
always think you should do it yourself
because I always think like I'm just a
big fan of that in general you know we
obviously aspire to be the best like
Vayner is one big attempt to do
something I don't believe in like I
believe that everybody should do
everything themselves you learn it's
cheaper you figure it out
mm I am big it's back to like like
almost like this fun world I live in and
so what veiners entire Sasha Porsche or
Vayner for sure is if you have to how do
I create the greatest solution to
something I don't believe in it's why
it's working took me a while to realize
that's what I was doing yeah I see that
but you make a lot of mistakes you do
you do and I think that's why we build
vein or talent we're starting to
understand it starting to think about it
differently we have a new product we're
gonna roll out on the gallery media side
to help people start their podcasts
there's stuff I'm figuring out I think
of myself as like like the Incredible
Hulk
right like I was a scientist I had this
thesis and I don't remember exactly was
it by accident but like to me I'm like
I'm taking my own like the way I decided
to prove to the whole world that I was
super right about how to brand was to
make myself the most famous [ __ ]
person in America from a place where
people didn't think you could build that
kind of level of fame and that's kind of
like the process I'm in I think one day
that whole trajectory of like first you
do marketing for your own business
then you do it for others then you do
the back for yourself like I almost
think like they'll like there'll be a
model named after me because I think
there's a lot of people that will do it
like me let me give you an insight that
might help you with this next chapter
where you're building out the agency
don't be scared for people to leave once
you build them up most people walk that
fine line like if you build up Carol or
the shop
well then Gary can hire them for Sasha
and that's where people lose you need to
create a system that everybody wants to
go into that's how I think about it the
reason I'm willing to like build up
d-roc and you know and I'm happy that
babban got the Adobe thing and like you
know Claude and James and like the
reason I do that is because first of all
you have to be confident that you're
bigger than all of it - because
anybody's better than you you already
got a problem
second humans are animals they'll sense
if you're suppressing it and because
Karma's good like if you if you helped
Carol get put on and she gets in $60,000
raise and Luke gets to move back to San
Francisco where family is that's just
putting good into the world
you don't I've read I mean look I've
been more than happy to not want to lose
a good executive but but I don't pay
ransom for sure anybody that even if
they're the number one all-time person
and they come in with ransom DN like
vibes it's already over
I've always laughed about that when
somebody comes to go scary gotta talk to
you the other plant you know I'm like
you're fine like do you like it like
it's already like they could they could
be the single most important person
there indeed they're already gone cuz
I'm not that's just gonna make me
unhappy that makes me feel like a
[ __ ] loser so that's number one
number two if they come and say hey I
love when they come in and try to make
me part of the process I'll over pay if
you come at me correctly hey I love it
here you've been such a mentor I've got
this crazy opportunity's hard I've got
college loans like I've sometimes
thought somebody was a C and paid up
because I like the way they came at me
and then and then sometimes you let them
walk cuz you can't afford it the Delta
and you know they're overrated by their
association with the best so there's a
lot of people here
think they're a lot better than they are
because they're associated with me and
sometimes you can't close that Delta and
you're happy for them
that wasn't like a rep yeah it was a
little bull res but it was far more of a
happy I'm like oh like you're going to a
competitor making [ __ ] fifty five
percent more because you're wearing a
Boehner jersey and they need that DNA in
the building I'm happy for I'm happy
listen good is good there are people
who've literally on the way out of here
because we fired them but I let them
control their communications have told
people that they're quitting have said
that I'm the biggest piece of [ __ ] of
all time and I'm completely full of [ __ ]
burned everything around them in their
last week before they left and three
years later are referring business to us
because because if you're right if
you're in a good place you're in a good
place
of course people gonna go to glass door
and tell everybody vaynermedia sucks or
their best friend at vaynermedia sucks
when they get fired people don't like
getting fired who likes getting fired
nobody thinks you're right but over time
they get context and as long as I am
kind and my intent is right and I'm
trying to do the right things that plays
out and I'm okay with being judged
definitely by the outside you know that
comment right but even willing to be
judged with people that should know
better because they're right here
because they're in pain at the time
you